[Applaudissements]
21 janvier 2017
des millions d'américaines sorte pour
dénoncer l'arrivée au pouvoir de dans
notre chemin
un an plus tard ces femmes sont encore
outré par le comportement du nouveau
président nous sommes à minneapolis au
minnesota
près de douze mois après la marche des
femmes plusieurs souhaitent aujourd'hui
transformer leur colère en action des
guerrières démocrate et républicaine se
sont donné rendez-vous pour apprendre à
faire de la politique qui dirige
l'organisation votre only l enseigne
d'abord aux femmes comment raconter leur
histoire est touchée de futurs électeurs
l'expérience est brutal pour plusieurs
la politique n'est pas fait beaucoup de
monde plusieurs choisissent de se mettre
complètement à nu carbone tecau du
michigan raconte le jour où elle s'est
fait poignardé par un inconnu
en entrant chez elle elle en a perdu
l'usagé d'un oeil
[Musique]
des histoires de vie bouleversante qui
posent ces femmes à l'action publique
[Applaudissements]
l'idée ici est de faire de la politique
autrement en restant soi-même
après cette expérience difficile voire
même pénible pour certaines les
participantes reprennent leurs esprits
jacqueline cordova qui était sans voix
sur sun soit que les femmes s'imposent
davantage wal fadjri qu est cette fois
sans chris doyle de notre existence est
à ce point presse
[Musique]
les voix de ces femmes résonne aussi à
l'autre bout du pays en utah dans
l'ouest américain où nous nous sommes
rendus
[Musique]
il y a un an elles ont envahi la
législature à salt lake city
en réaction à l'élection de tschopp et
non plus l'intention de se taire même
dans cet état ultra-conservateur 6000
groupe de résistance partout aux
états-unis sont nées de la dernière
élection présidentielle
joanna smith républicaine mormone et
mère de quatre enfants a été bouleversé
par la victoire du milliardaire du jour
au lendemain elle devient activistes et
fonde son propre groupe
pour contrer ces politiques de droite
docteur en éducation et républicaine
depuis toujours vise rien de moins qu'un
siège à la chambre des représentants à
washington pour représenter lutte et
contrer l'effet trump souhaite changer
son parti trop à droite selon elle qui
divise le pays
pendant ce temps au minnesota ces
novices en politique terminent leur
formation des musulmanes choqué par les
politiques anti immigration de trump
montrent aussi offrant h mohamed 25 ans
soit de se présenter comme conseillère
municipale à minneapolis
certaines crois que jobs a réveillé les
femmes et les états unis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces femmes quittent cette fête semaine
intensive de formation photo de campagne
inclus
quelques-unes seulement feront le grand
saut en politique mais toutes sont
convaincus que les états unis et le
monde se porterait beaucoup mieux
le jour où plus de femmes seront au
pouvoir
m